we're about to dive into sunday's
nominations which happens to be
the most diverse in oscar history
nichelle
five years ago hashtag oscar so white
brought a long-standing problem to the
forefront can you take us through that
movement yeah definitely drew you know
this
started in uh 2015 this campaign uh
hashtag oscar so white after every
single one of the acting categories
um were devoid of persons of color and
so
the academy realized that they did have
a problem and they decided we have to
take steps
to right these wrongs so back in 2020
they attempted to do just that they took
a first step and they brought in 819 new
members
to the academy they wanted it to be a
diverse group of people and it was 45
of those folks were women 36 of those
folks were from underrepresented groups
so
um the you know people of color in the
industry and then another 39
of them were international actors and
people from other countries
so they could bring different
perspectives show uh films from
different perspectives so the academy
has gone a long way to trying to right
those wrongs and this year i think we
will
see a banner moment when every single
one of the acting categories
could be and probably will be won by a
person of color
um we have a graphic of over the last
decade so over the last 10 years
those six actors in the middle are the
only actors of color
that have won an academy award you see
them young mahershala ali
octavia spencer viola davis and we've
got regina king
rami malek those six actors right there
are the only
actors in the last 10 years that have
won academy awards
well let's check out the first category
here are the nominees
for best actor in a leading role kevin
talk us through this group i just want
to start with
the fact that look gary oldman was great
in bank he is great at making its old
school hollywood look
and a lot of people like him as a
favorite but rizzamet
in the sound of metal is spectacular i
think he is one of the great young
actors and stephen yoon
and minari the way he goes through this
movie with emotion and heart
you will love it but let's not forget
chadwick boseman's nomination for ma
rainey's black bottom
talking to his co-stars and they talked
about his process
and how deeply he was in this and that
they didn't know
how sick he was and he fought through
to give this incredible performance
this is his oscar and he
deserves this oscar it was a spectacular
performance and by the way
it marks the first time in oscar history
that this category
is not majority white men so it is very
important and also
let's not forget sir anthony hopkins in
um the father watch for sir
anthony hopkins if he were too upset he
would be the oldest ever best actor
winner at 83 years old
okay let's see who our vff's predicted
um will win best actor in a leading role
chadwick goes ahead well thank you very
much
bff thank you so much all right let's
take a look at the nominees for best
actress in the leading role nichelle
we've got viola davis for ma rainey's
black bottom andrew day for the united
states versus billie holiday vanessa
kirby for pieces of a woman
frances mcdormand for nomad land and
kerry mulligan
for promising young women every single
one of these performances was
spectacular yes i mean they really were
spectacular every single one of these
women
brought something special to this role
and i don't know how you pick
it's come down to a three-person race i
don't know if this one is settled i
think viola davis
andrade and frances mcdormand are all
fighting this one out and so
if any of their their names are called
on sunday night i wouldn't be surprised
i think this race best actress is the
closest race of the night
this one absolutely francis mcdormand
won the bafta which is the british
academy award andrew day won the golden
globe
viola davis won the screen actors guild
award it is a
toss up let's see who our vff's
predicted will win best actress in a
leading role they picked
viola wow let's take a look at the
nominees for best supporting actor kevin
do you have a favorite when you look at
these men and their performances
they have been transcended sasha baron
cohen let's not forget trial of chicago
seven he was just as good
in the borat film and he has become this
versatile actor that we look at and we
love all right
i thought daniel kahlua and judas and
the black messiah
was incredible yeah the acting was
brilliant
oh my goodness when you talk about
leslie odom jr
a great talent one night in miami and
he was sam cook and what he sang you
lost your mind he was scared to play
this role because he didn't know if he
could do sam cook justice
and he did and so did andra day as billy
holliday and
that's what i'm saying when an actor can
harness the music
and the performance it's very
overwhelming to the voter and i think
you get kind of a double win
i still think daniel wins all right i do
too people who are vfs predicted will
win best supporting actor they picked
come to very close second
of sasha baron cohen i think they're
neck and neck right now and they're both
so
wonderful i think that would be the
definition of win-win all right don't go
anywhere because we're making more oscar
predictions including our pick for
best pick after the break but first here
is catherine zeta jones
with her favorite oscar moment one of my
favorite
favorite oscar moments was a real real
family affair it was the year that
chicago was nominated for best picture
i was humbled enough to be nominated and
to win that year for
velma kelly but best picture was being
presented by
kirk douglas and michael douglas
so as you know the end of the show is
best picture so we waited and waited and
waited and there comes my father-in-law
and my husband
and they opened the envelope they looked
at it
they ripped up the piece of paper and
shouted together in unison
chicago and that for me
would made something that i thought
could never be more memorable
memorable beyond belief
[Music]
you